so good afternoon everyone and uh I'm
Delight delighted to see such a crowd so
kind of proves that the topic is
relevant so let's see if I can meet the
expectations
um first before I actually start talking
about what the problems are and how we
solve them a bit of background because
of course who am I and why am I
somebody who can tell you about time
series and how to address this right
there's a lot of
a lot of things out there so I as was
mentioned I'm from the Nellis I work for
a company called cbx CBA data
specifically and we essentially our
consulting company helping in the domain
of data so that means in my day-to-day
life I joined different companies
usually sort of maturing data teams that
are doing great stuff but kind of
lagging behind actually putting stuff to
production effectively so that is
essentially identifying issues they have
helping them address that and well just
very often it happens to be time series
type of problems so overall the time I
gathered quite a bit of sort of common
problems that are simple after you
actually know them but not that obvious
at all when you actually just skip it
over so that's a little bit what we'll
see today
um
but before that maybe someone
got in the wrong room or just never
heard about time series in general so
why should you in general care
um well as you as you probably know and
I think it was mentioned in the previous
keynote talk right essentially time
series are a major part of pretty much
any company's agenda because we care not
about just today or yesterday we care
about things in Dynamics right and a
Time series problem is essentially
anything that you care about measured
not only today once but measured
continuously over time and that
essentially gives us a beautiful ability
to learn about what might happen in the
future based on what happened in the
past right but for that we need to take
into account all this complicated time
related stuff which makes the problem
sequential so not just a bunch of random
data points like you usually see in sort
of more traditional machine learning
problems and it also happens that there
are a lot of sort of interesting
artifacts and problems that originate
specifically from the nature of Time
series and timestamps themselves and as
it often happens so we data Specialists
required versatile right so not everyone
works exclusively on time series so it's
quite easy to overlook some of these
things
further I should mention that not only
it's very prevalent problem it's also
very important one right typically
coincides with things like predicting
your Revenue the demand and a lot of
other things that you kind of want to
get right so that means that all these
problems are not just interesting but
they're also pretty important
um and that's pretty much what we will
try to address today I'll just mention
that again as I often see most of these
issues are kind of downplayed or
considered unimportant so hopefully
we'll prove it otherwise
and specifically I'll walk you through
it through just one particular large
project that I worked on last year that
was at the Energy company called fat and
file where we worked on energy demand
forecasting so quite a common but very
interesting problem
um and actually we
um it coincided that their team kind of
stumbled upon a lot of little problems
along the way that I think kind of
nicely captures typical things that I
see elsewhere so hopefully there will be
additional narrative to what we will see
in a bit and specifically we'll cover
four different
problems each in a different stage of
working on developing a solution to a
Time series problem and for each of them
we'll discuss well where do they come
from how can we best address it or how
should we not address it and for a few
of them I'll also provide some simple
code examples even though that's not the
major point of this talk
and yeah you will see a lot of Time
series plots which is great
all right uh but first sort of a bit
about the Dynamics of how typical time
series project typically goes and I
think a lot of you would immediately
think oh time series let's do Profit
lstm just train some fancy stuff but
that's a couple of steps further right
and there's some important steps that we
kind of forget about is they're not the
most exciting ones right you need to get
your data together from different
sources the quality is probably
questionable that a lot of artifacts you
need to detect and then for all of this
detected problems you need to choose a
way to address them and there's kind of
no rule of thumb solution in this world
and all of that kind of piles up into a
lot of things that as you can imagine
all affect your end result right because
as you know garbage in garbage out so
actually for three out of four issues
there will be all before training models
and not after or during
um so let's start from a rather simple
one which I think most of you can relate
to but yet it will show an important
lesson that we'll see sort of
reoccurring throughout this conversation
for instance seeing a problem and
spending a bit of time to understand
what is really going on instead of
taking an obvious shortcut which often
will mislead us
um and that is essentially about a
common problem where you need to connect
two different well let's say data sets
or pieces of information sources
together usually it's based on the time
right essentially when did each piece of
information come from and here I have a
little token example of essentially
observing energy costs over time and
simultaneously collecting data on
temperatures it doesn't matter here they
are together it could have been also to
disjoint data sets that's not the point
the point is we need to make one
important step and let us figure out
okay how do we exactly match Today's
Energy costs with the exact temperature
there was today and as you can see here
it doesn't exactly match
but from a first glance you can see like
it looks like it's just lagging behind
so probably the temperature sensors data
is uploaded the day after while the
costs are known immediately which could
have happened
um and again our goal is to address this
and really make sure that things match
as they should
um what are possible uh issues that can
trigger this type of data quality issue
well very often as as you probably
encountered in a lot of Time series
right data doesn't just come from your
company or some kind of reliable source
very often is governmental data I've
actually worked quite a lot with the
data from the Dutch statistical agency
and you actually see a lot of it is even
sort of hand inputted because you I saw
like 20 different ways of writing
February for instance which is kind of
remarkable and it could be a lot of
other things right so different types of
sensors different types of data
providers so just I think it's a safe
assumption to just think probably the
input data is a mess especially if we
have different sources
so back to this problem what is kind of
the obvious assumption that probably
many Junior data Specialists would make
here well it's it's probably just
lagging right so you kind of looked at
the head and you saw that maybe you just
saw all of them actually looking like
they're from yesterday so the first idea
well it's lagging let's just take a
delayed version of that and the problem
is solved
look at it for a second because this
clearly something not going right
don't have to shout out the answer is
just reflect it and as you could have
noticed then we actually should have had
an observation in the second row but
instead we're missing it right so you
actually see that the dates are not
matching if you carefully look at it and
again like here it's obvious but if
you're just looking at a bunch of random
rows from a large data set that's really
not something you would immediately spot
right so the real mistake was to make an
assumption that you could have verified
but you didn't because it seemed like a
trivial problem
so what could be better solution
um make it explicit right so my biggest
tip and it applies not only to this
problem don't take shortcuts don't think
that obvious things are always the way
to go always take a step back look at
the full problem and think about what is
the most reliable explicit and clear
solution to this problem so even to the
simple problem the most explicit
solution is to make sure that every date
matches by construction so when you join
based on the date right whatever is a
problem will explicitly come out of the
result of this joining right so you see
here that since we requested it to be
joined on the dates explicitly whenever
there's a mismatch so if a date is
missing or something is duplicate it
will be reflected respectfully and that
means you can directly then measure what
are sort of the data issues that
originate from this operation and most
importantly you don't just leak some
kind of flawed human logic into your
data and as a result into your model as
well
an additional little tip it's also just
here of course it's available but it's
great to have timestamp for every piece
of collected information right because
also what I've seen is you get
temperature and it kind of looks like
um almost a four months but maybe a
couple days are missing and you actually
don't know when it was collected so if
you in any way control where the data is
coming from getting timestamp for pretty
much every step that you can measure is
usually a good idea
um also short remark if you have
questions because there'll be four
blocks maybe just make a mental note and
we'll come back to it in the end I think
this will be better for the flow of the
conversation
all right and to sort of wrap up this
first block let's have a look at a
potential code solution which is perhaps
not super exciting right because I think
majority of you have done uh joins and
merges before anyone who has never done
or seen it
great
maybe something less obvious rights also
make it explicit so which uh what kind
of columns you're merging on or maybe
even some additional checks and I don't
have it here but also additional tip
testing right so whatever you're doing
make sure there's a test that kind of
measures the result of the operation but
if you did it this way instead of a lag
you wouldn't have any issues with this
problem
all right
um then if this one was clear let's move
to the second step right so we've just
seen what could go wrong potentially
during the data collection stage again
don't think that this is the only thing
that can go wrong of course there are
multiple others but hopefully each of
these blocks kind of gives you an idea
what you should typically expect so that
you can take this time yourself for your
problem
so the second step and again also don't
take it as ground truth always for you
this might look a little bit different
but again it kind of gives you an
average truth of what I would typically
see in a Time series project
so the Second Step here is inspection
analytics and finding issues right so
essentially you got everything you need
but again as I said just assume that
there are problems because almost always
they are when you think they aren't
that's even worse because it means
they're very hidden
um so in this case we'll see something
that might look like there aren't any
issues at all but in fact if you would
look at it a bit more carefully you
would make your life in the future much
easier
so let's have a look at this
time series right so you see some this
is generated data by the way so no
company data was exposed uh but this is
a pattern that you see very very often
right so essentially some cyclical
fluctuations right a lot of business
data in time Series has this sort of
repetitive seasonal pattern right think
about energy consumption throughout the
year more in the winter Less in the
summer for the heating
um unless you're in California and you
use crazy amount of air costs either way
right you have these fluctuations but
you have something else here which isn't
very obvious that is the increasing
magnitude of the fluctuations right
sometimes it's just part of the problem
it's just sort of what happens behind
the hood you have no way of identifying
what is actually happening so I've seen
a lot of data Specialists kind of trying
to explicitly tackle this problem so if
you train models you could do something
like multiply your features by the time
feature to sort of add this Dynamic
component to the problem so you could in
principle solve this with some kind of
like increasing magnitude sign curve
translated in the future here but if you
again take this fast Brute Force
approach you actually trying to solve
more problems than you potentially
cancel for at the very least you make
your life much much more difficult
and if you think about this right so
this is energy usage over time again
think to yourself don't have to shout it
out what is probably going on behind the
hood right let's say we're like a young
emergent Energy company that's becoming
increasingly popular over time
well that's what every company wants
right we're growing so more people are
joining in and if this happens to be
aggregate data it's quite natural that
this is essentially a function of the
number of customers that we have and
very often it would indeed turn out that
if you look at something like number of
clients that you have over time it's
something like this right which
essentially translates into that
increasing fluctuations that we saw
before so if you took a step back and
thought about that and identified this
course of the issue that we saw before
you can actually now disentangle the
problem and say okay I'm not going to
brute force it and solve sort of
aggregate energy consumption over time
that incorporates the growth of the
business in it I will separate so we'll
essentially see for
um essentially if we divide the
consumption by the number of customers
we have one problem that is interesting
for us that it's just let's say per
household what a typical seasonal
fluctuations of the energy consumption
which is one problem and another problem
is predicting business growth over time
right which are both interesting
relevant important problems but this way
maybe two teams can work in it both have
their own approaches issues and then you
can always combine the results together
and of course debugging and evaluating
this will be also way way way easier
let's see so if indeed you divide it in
this case you get this amazingly equal
generated data
um I don't have a code example here
because I if you all did merges I think
everyone has divided one column by the
values in the other
so allow me to skip this one
all right let's go to third one and it's
going to get a bit more uh Advanced and
interesting perhaps if so far you've
been
warmed up enough
so that's the third step so that's right
before you get your data ready for
actually doing something with it that is
when you have already got stuff together
identified all of or at least most of
the potential problems in it and then
you're trying to address it again there
could be all kinds of issues I'll show
you one interesting one because it I
think it's quite a bit to learn there
and it also generalizes well to related
types of issues in Time series and also
what is nice and time serious that
solutions that you know from elsewhere
don't really work so well
specifically that will be about imputing
missing values in Time series right as
you probably know for regular tabular
data it's not so complicated right just
replace with the mean median most common
value
now here well you could technically do
that but of course remember everything
is dynamic right so it's important not
just what the value is but what are the
neighboring values sort of where are we
in the whole dynamic over time
and in this case you see that it also
unfortunately happens that all these
missing values are kind of clustered
together which also very often happens
in reality think about things like
weather making impact on things so a
real example
um we're also looking at uh generated
wind power or like maintenance of the
windmills in the ocean as you know
there's like million of them between
England and Netherlands and if there's
like a huge storm or something pretty
bad is going on then this is also when
you will get all kinds of data anomalies
right so what's important they're all
cluster together so if you try to use
some kind of simple Brute Force approach
not only it will not be a very good
solution you will actually introduce
something that is additionally
problematic so actually you'll do
something that I would call a normally
propagation so you'll basically will
introduce a problem and
exaggerate it over time so which kind of
only makes things worse so for example
right if you take a look at this three
missing value over here if you just take
a common approach which is just kind of
backfill so you take the previous value
and copy it
for the the following subsequent missing
values you can immediately see we kind
of generate this relatively high value
flat curve which is probably not
something you would observe in reality
right well again here I happen to
actually have the True Values and this
is actually from a real data set that's
um I believe it's from 2008 French
household energy consumption data set
that you can look up on Google if you're
interested
but essentially what we want to do is to
replace it in a meaningful way that kind
of addresses the whole dynamic pattern
and not just what happened yesterday or
the day before that
so again we're going to take a step back
look at it from this perspective and
realize that we need more flexible
Dynamic approach that will address the
actual issue instead of some kind of
duct tape and glue as we've seen
elsewhere and this there are multiple
clever approaches that you can take here
so I'll just show you one that I
personally like quite a bit
and that is using something called
exponentially smoothed values as a
replacement now that's something not
every one of you might have heard so
bear with me I will explain it one by
one don't look at the bottom graph so
let's focus on the top one that will
make understanding a little bit easier
um so what you see here the blue the
dark blue values are what we actually
know right then there is the
um I believe the
bluish border and white inside that's
that's what we actually missing
um and the green ones again this is
something special so we're doing
something called exponential smoothing
um so most of you must have heard about
at least something like moving average
right this is kind of a more
sophisticated
solution in that family of smoothing
algorithms again the math is a little
bit less trivial so I'm not going to
write out whole equations but there's a
simple idea behind it is that every
exponentially smooth value is
essentially a weighted average between
yesterday's smooth value
and today's actual value
there's like a parameter you can play
around with I'll show you in a second in
the code
but again the idea is that it's
something that we kind of start growing
from the beginning and it takes sort of
a geometrically declining history into
account in at every single point but at
the end of the day it's always a balance
between today's value and some sort of
smooth value yesterday so if you if you
got that then you're already with me
um there is an additional problem though
right so you start growing the smooth
curve and then it encounters a missing
value so we need to add an additional
solution to that and this is actually
where it's okay to use the previous
value which is not the value of the
actual observation but actually the
previous smooth value would be
propagated for the subsequent missing
value right remember we're waiting today
and the smooth value yesterday if we
don't have today well let's just copy
the smooth value from yesterday that's
why you see for instance here right it's
the Green Point that is being propagated
three times not the dark blue point
all right
um so if you understood this now
actually just a little part is left that
is essentially taking the green points
every time we have a missing value and
replacing the missing value with those
points remaining green points well here
we don't really care about them but as a
side note well exponential smoothing is
kind of a nice tool to keep in your
pocket anyways so you might use it
elsewhere so now to the bottom plot
because here we're actually combining
three different things so we have again
the dark blue points the actual observed
values then we have the red points those
are the actual unobserved values so if
we knew the truth that's ideally where
we want to be right so the closer to
that the better and then we have sort of
two candidate Solutions so yellow is
forward fill
I think I called it backfield
accidentally so no forward feel right in
this case so from yesterday to tomorrow
and that's exactly what you see here and
in green is our new favorite essentially
replacing with exponentially smooth
values as you can see it's actually most
of the time it's doing quite a lot
better of course this is like kind of a
Cherry Picked example but trust my word
if you do it for a bunch of problems and
you compare the solution which is
something you can actually measure so
feel free to play around with this as a
sort of exercise maybe to try to prove
me wrong or find it find whether that
applies to you or not but very often
you'll see that this works quite a lot
better and I think it also has intuitive
sense to it right we're not just looking
at whatever happened yesterday which
might be also affected by a lot of
anomalies and other factors we're
looking at the dynamic history and
that's what you care about in Time
series
all right
then
let's have a look at this code example
it looks complicated but actually not so
much is going on here because in pandas
it's quite easy to implement exponential
smoothing
um essentially all you need to do is
use this method here with a parameter
that is the weight between the two and
then this will ensure that we've forward
filled the missing values during
exponential smoothing once you do that
you get your green curve then everything
that is left is essentially feeling and
this is actually very easy with this
method that is combined first so if
there is a value we don't do anything
there's a missing value we get it from
the second column
so quite neat
so quite a complicated approach all
fitted in just two lines of code
essentially
all right well then the last but not the
list
probably what we all thought about in
the beginning it's the actual modeling
that's kind of a chapter of itself right
so I'll bring one just to kind of make
it a closed up story but I think this is
where many more issues would be found so
I think the first three are kind of the
more authentic one in the stock
uh but here's an interesting one that
will also make you think of the same
idea right it's essentially taking a
step back looking at our problem and
only then starting to solve it so here
we see again that um single household
energy consumption over four years and
we're trying to predict it essentially
on a daily basis and this is exactly
what the model would model output would
look like I would kind of omit what the
model is here that's actually not
critical what is important we're just
using the raw data as the input here
essentially
and that's also very often how people go
about it like okay we have the raw data
let's try the feed model over it we
don't really think about okay how does
that actually translate into what we're
trying to address as you can see here
there's kind of a lot of weird things
with the model trying to pick up all of
the individual fluctuations that might
not be something that you really care
about overall
so this is where I would again recommend
to take a step back and realize that
well maybe those crazy fluctuations is
not something you're actually trying to
predict maybe you just care about how
does a energy consumption pattern look
like over time on average right and that
actually should have implications for
what you're feeding into the model right
because if you're telling the model try
to predict all of that it will try to
succeed at all this crazy Peaks and
that's actually not something you wanted
so if you took a step back and you kind
of reformulated the problem you might
now actually use smooth values and here
you can again use my favorite
exponential smoothing because maybe
that's actually something you care about
predicting right so essentially we
figured that we can transform the
problem and not only make it easier for
the model to predict over but we
actually get closer to the truth that
we're trying to address
which is arguably something we should
aim for in a Time series project
all right we kind of
short on time I have here a little
example of how you would do that in
principle but actually it all just
breaks down to replacing your train set
with the smooth values rather than
the original raw values so allow me to
skip that one because I still would like
to address some questions and maybe just
a little side note
if you find it interesting or
fascinating just reach me out connect
with me and I'm happy to address more
issues on that matter or just time
series in general because that's for
sure a fascinating topic to talk about
so the last bit is again take a step
back look at your problem make the right
choice and this will get you two steps
forward thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much um there are six
questions well I don't know if you have
time but let's start with the first
it says the second topic was
disentangling of two times series do you
have any tips on how to disentangle if
the underlying relations are not so
obvious
yeah that's that's kind of a million
dollar question right
um I don't think I have a rule of thumb
here I would say the best tip is talk to
so the question was how do you
disentangle two-time series like we did
with aggregate energy and customers when
it's not obvious again there is no rule
of thumb I would say my best tip talk to
people that actually get this data be it
I don't know workers building the
windmills or analysts collecting the
data that's the best way to get to the
truth but probably the best I can advise
here
so another question is about you talked
about exponentials moving for imputing
can you take uncertainty into account if
you do um
if you do other methods can I take one
into account uncertainty into account if
you use other methods then exponential
is moving
uh yes so there are definitely more
sophisticated ones right so this is kind
of to find the middle ground for a
general audience right there are more
sophisticated methods where you can kind
of construct your own type of smoothing
which indeed would take sort of the
local uncertainty into account as well
and if you really want to be precise
that's indeed a good idea but I'm not
going to throw around technicalities
here I think that's too much for an
average person
another question is about um
how would you in real world modeling
problem where you do not know the
missing data point values decide which
moving algorithm works best for feeling
also great question
um the best solution is I would say
hyper parameter tuning so that's
something you can actually parameterize
just like there was this Alpha remember
the weight I nobody asked right but
that's also like why 0.5 and not 0.1
parameterize right so use it explicitly
as a parameter of your machine learning
pipeline you can do like a custom
Transformer and so I could learn for
that and you can perfectly determine the
answer empirically right doing your
favorite cross-validation and grade
search or whatnot
yeah
so maybe a very last one how would you
train a neural network when time points
with data is heavily irregularly spaced
impute missing values also over long
time period
well it's a great one but I'll say uh
that could be a great topic for another
talk so I'll address it at the next
opportunity like that thank you
[Applause]
um